make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so picking up with the next part
did you guys really think I was gonna
leave you on a cliffhanger do you really
think I was gonna leave you hanging
today not at all right we gotta keep we
got to keep this going man man keep this
going the power of divine spawn and holy
it is amazing right so what this does is
this picks up really with kind of like
the beginning of the end of things
essentially like Armageddon in full
swing and now initially there are some
strange things going on here that will
be explained later on as we as we kind
of go through but with cyan essentially
having helped spawn you know and during
the time when she was helping him face
off against the disciple there was this
kind of protective sphere that was
created around cyan to make sure that
nothing could harm her right that she'd
be able to focus explicitly on what it
was that she was doing and not have to
worry about anything else now outside of
the sphere is Wanda and Terry but as we
end up seeing here there's basically
this kind of you know monster looking
thing that basically starts trying to
hammer against this fear and destroy it
ah with with Wanda and Terry and em cyan
inside now of course it is holding and
it is keeping them protected but this
monster being there is really kind of
the indication of okay this is where
everything is really sort of coming to
an end right the rise of the Four
Horsemen and all that kind of stuff and
so picking up with the aftermath of the
disciple having killed spawn we get the
reason why this took place and the
reason for that is because with regards
to how this functions the disciple you
know the the the I guess the element of
the personality of judas iscariot as we
know from judeo-christianity basically
ratted on Jesus right turned to Jesus in
in the spawn mythos it was done because
the only way for Jesus's life to have
any meaning was if he was crucified and
the only way for him to be crucified was
for Judas Iscariot to basically turn him
in so it was the role that Judas played
spawn is much the same way spawn has to
die and then be reborn again in order to
basically experience all this power
right - to kind of be reborn as this new
version of himself and that was kind of
the on running theme right technically
the mother of creation killed God and
Satan and then they were reborn in human
form right so it's more or less the same
process when it comes to spawn the issue
with this is is what the mother of
creation does is she basically says that
in the in the beginning of humanity when
Adam and Eve were created and they ate
from the tree of knowledge of good and
evil it's scared God right because God
was now scared of the fact of what they
could achieve did they could in turn by
having knowledge of good and evil also
know of the
Tree of Life and in consuming or eating
from the tree of life they would become
immortal and then become gods much like
God and Satan hat that was the fear
that's why they were cast out of of the
Garden of Eden and that's why they
represent out into the world and then
things just kind of progressed from
there and so what the mother of creation
does is basically take fruit from the
tree of life and then feed it to Al
Simmons and when that happens Al Simmons
is completely resurrected now with that
being the case
he's now divine spawn or at least he has
all this like an insane amount of power
to him now it's kind of interesting
because spawn doesn't really know all
the power that he has but he will figure
it out and we will see what it is that
he can do with all this power that he's
been granted but one of the ways in
which you differentiate between divine
spawn and regular spawn are the angel
wings that's usually like if you ever do
a Google search for a divine spawn
that's what you will see spawn with
angel's wings but that's really kind of
the the big differentiation here now the
other part of this is the 6000 souls
that were bonded to spawn have now
basically been allowed to leave his body
the knowledge and experience that he
gained from those souls are still part
of spawn himself but the souls
themselves are now out leaving and doing
their own thing including Christopher
but the idea here is that now is its
spawns job to go out into the world and
essentially save it right that's the
entire purpose of spawn at this moment
and so one of the first things he does
is he stumbles across this old man and
we get this first little indication of
spawns power right insofar as this man
comes running at him with a stick and
Swan basically makes the stick disappear
and then says tell me what's going on
here and this is when we get an
indication of what it what had happened
right for the world out there they
didn't really know what was going on
right I mean aside from what was going
on inside of the House of Wanda and
Terry nobody knew what was taking place
for them it was business as usual people
were going to work people were we're
getting you know doing their thing the
news is being reported all that kind of
stuff and then out of nowhere the four
horsemen is start to rise the first one
comes pestilence right and all those who
were in a shadow basically start
experiencing all these forms of plagues
right this idea that like their skin
starts melting off and different things
along those lines the swarm of insects
just come flying out of nowhere with the
with the horseman of death right but
basically death starts bringing death to
all these various humans around it
around the same time that happens famine
rises and famine basically drives people
to this point of extreme hunger but
never being able to be satiated right
it's kind of a hunger in their soul they
can never fully satisfy and then the
final Horseman to show up is the
horseman of war
and this this kind of screamer this kind
of shot that it makes drives people back
down into their most primal based forms
twists and screws them up and that's the
kind of being that we saw trying to tear
up and trying to destroy the force field
that was basically protecting cyan Wanda
and Terry and so following that the Four
Horsemen across the apocalypse are the
Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse start
wreaking havoc everywhere right the the
forces of Hell are more or less kind of
solidified in these these sort of you
know twisted screwed up versions of
humanity but at this point what you end
up getting is kind of like these armies
of Heaven and Hell who are basically
marching to this one particular Island
and the reason why is because this is
where the final battle is going to take
place and it's kind of interesting
because the way it's depicted here is
they're within eyesight of each other
all the forces of heaven have to do is
look to the right and like all the
forces of Hell are right over there all
the forces of Hell have to do is look to
the left and all the forces of heaven
are right there but they're there
they're basically being drawn to this
one island to this one location to
basically fight against each other now
once they get there that's when the
battle begins to take place and spawn it
basically travels to that that direct
location and comes into contact with
Zahra now remember Zahra is kind of like
this this super powerful agent of heaven
right so she's like the double-oh-seven
of heaven more or less I guess I don't
really know how to quantify that but
she's super powerful right I mean
whoever she was the one who was able to
like decimate the forces of Hell when
they had entered heaven right the
Forgotten more or less she decimated all
of them single-handedly and so with
spawn approaching her you know it's one
of these things were is kind of a
vendetta against the tube she initially
looks at him and says like you're a hell
spawn my job is to destroy you because
you threaten the rule of God and it's
kind of crazy because initially her her
rage if you guys recall manifests in the
form of a giant beast spawn takes this
beast out like that it happens in
seconds right it's it's ridiculous how
fast it gets destroyed it's kind of nuts
here you know with that happening he in
turn starts to go after Zahra and Zahra
puts up a good fight but it's like nope
like she gets she gets taken out quick
fast and in a hurry those are the guys
who are looking to quantify this imagine
a singular being powerful enough to take
out the Living Tribunal and marwah
comics in the blink of an eye imagine
that that's basically what this is right
like the beyonders more or less God out
there created Zahra as like his number
one person right the number
the top person in his arsenal the one he
sends forward to take everything out the
Living Tribunal s kind of a character
Swan comes along done so that's it right
like she goes to cut spawn in half and
then spawn it just basically heals
himself and then just starts smashing
Zahra Wright is absolutely just like
crushing this girl and then just sort of
just leaves her there right and then
following that punches a hole in her and
then decapitate sir right basically just
like rips her head off and that's the
end of her following that he starts
going forward as he's making his way to
where God and sing the wrath you have
basically the last two of these massive
demon monsters fighting each other and
and one of them is essentially taken out
and then starts you know kind of lets
out this scream of pain spawn follows
the load follows the the shout only to
realize that it's basically granny
bullet my granny Blake was the last
soldier fighting and when when the armor
begins to kind of go away right like
spawn destroys this demon pretty fast
but when the armor starts to kind of
melt away and it reveals granny granny
Blake that she basically says nothing
was what we thought it was you were
right
God and Satan are our dicks right like
they're they're like really crappy
people they're not what we thought they
were we thought like God was caring and
loving and loving love just like the
Father and that kind of a thing no like
we're pawns in this great big huge game
and you tried to tell me that was true
and I didn't believe that the responsive
spawn and this is really kind of cool
here the response to spawn is I
understand that but the heaven that
you've been shown by this God is not the
true heaven there's got to be a real
heaven out there a real afterlife for
all these people out there right this
cannot simply be it if there are other
gods on other planets all across the
universe then they're like what are the
gods go when they die right like what
what happens when all this takes place
there has to be some definitive
afterlife out there and that's where
you're going you're going to go to that
place and you're gonna experience
everlasting peace it's comforting right
it's comforting for granny Blake to know
that this isn't all there is right there
like this this was not it the shoe is
just a pawn and that the game of God and
Satan and that was it it's the honorable
thing that spawn does it's an incredible
thing that spawned us and so following
this the the power of divine spawn
really comes into fruition yet again
when he shows up to this location where
all these forces of Hell are fighting
and basically says this is my world you
have no place here if your loyalty is to
Satan then go back to Hell and almost
like somebody who can work reality on a
planetary and even a cosmic scale the
ground
literally opens and all these forces are
banished back to hell
all these health spawn are banished back
there right it's not a wish that like
the mother of creation granted spawn did
that himself spawn said all of you go
back to hell and then symptom there
right and that's where they are now
right I mean followed like with that
being said like the forces of Satan are
basically gone now right either they're
totally obliterated from there you end
up picking up with Satan himself and
same begins to kind of ask the question
like where are all my hell spawn like
something's missing here where all my
hell spawn at and that's when one of his
demons approaches him and says well like
spawn basically like like some hell
spawn out there with wings symp them all
back to hell I saw it with my own eyes
Satan gets pissed right rips this guy's
eyes out and then from there you end up
jumping to God and basically like spawn
shows up on the doorstep of God and you
know when he says where is there a spawn
says she's right here I've got her head
get out of here right like leave this
world this world belongs to me now
right like leave all of this and so
initially God and Satan you'll kind of
team up for a second and then go
directly after spawn and when that
happens spawn unleashes the full
totality of his power and probably one
of the most insane displays of the spawn
comic that I've ever seen
spawn unleashes the full totality of his
powers and says let this all be done and
using his abilities cleanses the
entirety of the earth he literally wipes
everything out it's nuts it says like
when he looked about him and saw what he
had done
spawn wept for all the world was
desolation and mankind was no more with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
- comments explained make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
round 4 if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like in the next
video we will pick up with the ending we
will pick up with spawn verses God and
Satan and I will catch you all later
peace
I want to say thank you to all of the
new patrons who have joined patreon.com
slash comics explained I want to give a
shout out to Henry young - Elias G David
J s Jacob H been John H Jason see Austin
s Austin H James O kristymatt in Jeff
our Joey M Steven Z sloth-like lu-david
see John H lean and mean that guy asked
questions all the time Adam Cajun gnosis
916 I want to say thank you to all of
you all this list is growing all the
time they were joining the patreon
[Music]